estimating sign of 0.4 using a Maclaurin
polynomial what is the least degree of
the polynomial that assures an error
smaller than 0.001 so what are we
talking about here well we could take
some function and estimate it with an
nth degree Maclaurin polynomial in fact
we could talk more generally about a
Taylor polynomial but let's just say
this is an nth degree Maclaurin
polynomial but this isn't going to be a
perfect approximation there's going to
be some error some remainder and so we
could call this the remainder of that
nth degree Maclaurin polynomial it's
going to be dependent for any given X
now if we want to use the specifics of
this exact problem we could phrase it
this way we want to say look if we're
taking the sine of 0.4 this is going to
be equal to our Maclaurin our nth degree
Maclaurin polynomial evaluated at 0.4
plus whatever the remainder is for that
nth degree
Maclaurin polynomial evaluated at 0.4
and what we really want to do is figure
out for what n what is the least degree
of the polynomial so what what is let me
do this in a different color so we want
to figure out what is the smallest n
what is the smallest n such such that
the remainder of our nth degree
Maclaurin polynomial evaluated 0.4 is
less than this number is less than 0.001
so this is just another way of
rephrasing the problem and the way that
we can do it is we can use something
called the Lagrangian and we have other
videos that prove it this is often also
too called Taylor's remainder theorem
and I'll first write it out and I'll try
to explain it while I write it out but
it'll actually become a lot more
concrete when we work it out so Taylor's
remainder theorem tells us or a little
garage error bound tells us that if
we're that if the derivative
plus one derivative of our function so f
so this is our n plus 1 the derivative
our function if the absolute value of
that is less than or equal to some M for
an open interval open interval
containing where our containing where
our polynomial is centered in this case
it's zero we're going to use the
Maclaurin case so it's containing zero
and the exit or zero and X the X that we
care about in this particular video is
zero point four but I'll say it in
generally for any X so if this is true
if our n plus want the derivative of our
function if the absolute value of it is
less than or equal to M over an open
interval containing where we're centered
this would be C if we're talking about
the general case and X so this X right
over here then then this is the Lagrange
this is the part that's useful we can
say that the remainder is bounded the
remainder for that nth degree polynomial
so this is the n plus 1 derivative
that's bounded then we can say the
remainder for the nth degree polynomial
that approximates our function is going
to be less than or equal to that M times
X to the n plus 1 or at times ya times X
to the n plus 1 over n plus 1 factorial
so how do we apply that to this to this
particular problem well think about the
derivatives of sine we know that the
absolute value of sine is less than or
equal to 1 its derivative is cosine of X
the absolute value of that is going to
be bounded is going to be less than or
equal to 1 so no matter how many times
we take the derivative of sine of X the
absolute value of that derivative is
going to be less than or equal to 1 so
we could write generally that for this
particular f of X so let's say for this
particular f of X right over here we
could say that the absolute value of f
the absolute value of the n plus 1
derivative evaluated any X is going to
be less than or equal to
and this is the case for where F is sine
where f is sine of X and this is
actually going to be true over any
interval it doesn't even have to be over
some type of a restricted interval where
we can do this so we know that this is
our M we know that this is our M that's
sine and its derivatives are all bounded
by or their absolute values are bounded
by one and so then we we have our M and
we can apply the Lagrange lagron Jar
around so we can say that the remainder
of our nth degree Maclaurin
approximation at 0.4 so our X in this
particular case is 0.4 we don't want it
we don't have to do it generally for any
X here it's going to be less than or
equal to our M is 1 so I won't even
write that down our x is 0.4 0.4 to the
x to the n plus 1 to the n plus 1 over n
plus 1 factorial and we're taking the
absolute value of this whole thing
this is lagron Jarrow bound and we want
to figure out if we can figure out a
situation where this is less than 0.001
then this for sure is going to be less
than 0.001 because the remainder is less
than this or less than or equal to this
which is less than that so how do we do
that how do we figure out the smallest n
where this is going to be true well we
can just try out some ends and keep
increasing until this thing actually
becomes smaller than that thing so let's
do it
all right I'm gonna set up a table here
so let me make a do it relatively
cleanly so let's do this is going to be
our N and then this is going to be this
is going to be 0.4 to the n plus 1 over
n plus 1 factorial so let's try it when
n is equal to 1 well then this is going
to be 0.4 to the - so it's 0.4 squared
over 2 factorial this is 0.16 over 2
which is equal to 0.08 that's definitely
not less than
one thousand here so let's try n equals
two when N equals two is going to be
zero point four to the third power over
three factorial
and that's equal to what is that zero
point I'm going to need three digits
behind the decimal zero point zero six
four over six well this is a little bit
more than one zero point zero one so
this isn't where iron isn't large enough
yet so let's try three so this is going
to be zero point zero four to the 3 to
the 3 plus one so that's going to be to
the fourth power over 4 factorial and
let's see that is going to be equal to
this is going to be let's see it's going
to have four digits behind the decimal
so zero point zero two five six over 24
this is we're almost there
this is a little bit this is going to be
a little bit more than 0.001 so that
doesn't that doesn't do the trick for us
so I'm guessing already that N equals
four is going to do the trick but let's
verify that so this is going to be zero
point zero four we're at a zero point
four I should say to the fifth power
over five factorial and what is this
equal to let's see 4 to the fifth is
1024 I'm going to have five numbers
behind the decimal and I'm going to vide
it by five factorial which is 120 and
let's see this right over here yes this
for sure is less than 0.001 this is
definitely less than a thousandth right
over here so we see that when n is equal
to four so we can say that the remainder
for our fourth degree polynomial fourth
degree Maclaurin polynomial evaluated at
x equals zero point four is for sure
going to be less than 0.001 so there you
go that is the least degree of the
polynomial that assures an error smaller
than one thousandth